répondre à ces attentes légitimes nous
les avons nous pas pousser dans les bras
d'un partenaire qui va en profiter pour
faire de l'iran sa tête de pont au moyen
orient
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter en partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nous et à des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche dont intérêts de
leurs populations
oui
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 28 septembre
2001 jean castex recevra ce mardi les
représentants de l'hôtellerie des cafés
de la restauration
une rencontre avec le premier ministre
alors que les établissements ont dû
fermer totalement à marseille et aix en
provence
le tribunal examinera demain le recours
déposé par le président les républicains
de la région provence alpes côte d'azur
renaud muselier contre cet arrêté
préfectoral dans les zones d' alerte
renforcée comme à paris les
établissements à baisseront le rideau
dès 22h ce soir réunion d'urgence au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu attendu
demain après l'intensification des
combats dans le haut karabakh territoire
que l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan se
disputent depuis 30 ans à 27 soldats
séparatistes arméniens tués aujourd'hui
est les décomptes officiels des deux
camps ne cesse d'évoluer depuis la
reprise du conflit
hier ankara washington moscou paris et
bruxelles
oslo
[Musique]
emmanuel macron en lituanie aujourd'hui
mais il devrait surtout s'exprimer sur
la contestation populaire chez le voisin
biélorusse le président rencontrera ce
mardi la chef de file de l'opposition
hier le chef de l'état fustigeait la
trahison de la classe politique
libanaise au lendemain de l'échec à
former un gouvernement sur tous les
fronts quelle est la stature des manuels
macron sur la scène mondiale at-il
restaurer la voix de la france
nous en parlerons dans notre débat
et on débute avec la situation sanitaire
en france et les derniers chiffres de
santé publique france l'agent s'annonce
plus de 12000 nouvelles contaminations
aux copies de 19 ans 24 heures
quatre-vingt-une personnes sont décédées
à l'hôpital et 780 patients sont
actuellement en réanimation un virus qui
circule activement sur les territoires
un nombre de combats de contamination
qui ne cesse de croître
faut-il encore durcir les mesures face
au regain de l'épidémie de corona virus
on en débarras tout de suite avec nos
invités et un face à face ce soir avec
bruno m'égare ban chef de service de
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière
bonsoir à vos côtés philippe froguel
généticien bonsoir alors bruno m'égare
manière vous avez cosigné une tribune
dans le jdd vous appelé le gouvernement
à prendre des mesures beaucoup plus
radicales et vous mettez en garde je
cite contre une deuxième vague est bien
plus difficile à gérer pour les hôpitaux
et les services de réanimation que la
première alors est-ce qu'on revient
réellement à une situation proche de
mars dernier
alors tout d'abord merci beaucoup alors
non nous n'avons pas interpeller le
gouvernement mais nous avons souhaité
alerter la population sur la situation
et expliquer les raisons pour lesquelles
nous nous trouvons désormais en
possibles difficultés
effectivement depuis maintenant quelques
semaines le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations augmente de façon
significative et malheureusement
maintenant depuis une dizaine de jours
le nombre d'admissions à l'hôpital est
en réanimation de cas plus graves de
lakovic 19 augmente avec dans certaines
grandes métropoles comme à marseille une
saturation du nombre de lits qui avait
été réservée pour la prise en charge de
ces patients
la situation à paris devient également
relativement alarmante puisque
aujourd'hui par exemple près de 175 lits
sur 502 capacitaire
de réanimation médicale et chirurgicale
à l'assistance publique des hôpitaux de
paris est occupée par des patients
présentant lakovic 19 en fait l'alertent
avait pour but d'inciter les citoyens à
plus de prudence et notamment une
meilleure application des mesures
barrières et du port du masque lorsque
celui ci est nécessaire principalement
pendant les réunions familiales élargie
ou amicales philippe froguel le
confinement que l'on pensait un dernière
nous est ce que c'est aujourd'hui
clairement une perspective à remettre
sur la table c'est un confinement voit
bien en voir plusieurs pays que ça peut
revenir on la vit en espagne on voit
dans d'autres pays
c'est même envisagé à berlin par madame
merkel
ça ça nous c'est quelque chose qui est
devant nous si effectivement comme le le
craignent un certain nombre de collègues
on arrive à une saturation à des
animations et des digues et d urgence
puisque rappelons-le a quand même en
mars et cette saturation qui a amené le
premier confinement la vraie question
c'est est-ce que vraiment on va jusqu'à
là et c est ce que les ce genre de
tribunes ciblant uniquement la
population des trucs et utile
personnellement moi je suis contre ces
tribunes je pense que les médecins les
savants sont ne sont pas là pour
morigéner la population ils sont là pour
analyser le real ce qui se passe et ça
ça a été fait je comprends très bien ils
sont et ils sont là pour proposer des
solutions pas simplement de dire le
montrer des drôles de figure en dix ans
avec des courbes exponentielle que le 15
novembre sera saturé personne n'en sait
strictement rien
par contre ce qui me semble important
c'est de conseiller le gouvernement
comment faire mieux et ça c'était pas
dans les tribunes récente et je trouve
que on se retrouve un peu de cibles
aujourd'hui même si effectivement il
faut rajouter vos dires un population de
faire attention à ça c'est évident bruno
megaman qu'est ce que vous répondez à
philippe froguel
qui vous dit à l'instant ce n'est pas il
ne faut pas à la s'adresser à la
population aujourd'hui
ne faut pas les culpabiliser ou font
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez à nouveau notre propos
n'étaient pas du tout de culpabiliser
quiconque
on va dire la situation est difficile
l'application des mesures barrière n'est
pas facile porter le masque n'est pas
évident simplement ce sont des conseils
que nous prodiguons effectivement nous
sommes tous acteurs et nous devons être
responsables car la circulation du virus
se fait par nous mêmes
le virus ne circule pas si nous-mêmes
nous ne faisons pas circuler le problème
ici c'est que le virus malheureusement
est traître c'est à dire en fait les
personnes qui le portent sont pour les
trois quarts d'entre elles
asymptomatique et donc ne savent pas
qu'elles vont malheureusement favoriser
sa circulation et contaminer d'autres
personnes
et puis malheureusement parmi ces
personnes il peut se trouver des
personnes plus âgées plus à risque de
faire des formes graves
c'est là la difficulté le deuxième
problème essentiel c'est qu'il existe un
délai d'une quinzaine de jours entre la
contamination et l'expression de la
maladie est là aussi et c'est pourquoi
nous souhaitions attirer l'attention sur
la situation épidémiologique tous que le
nôtre on observe actuellement reflète ce
qui s'est passé il y a quinze jours
or depuis les contaminations augmenter
de façon importante et en fait dans 15
jours nous sommes inquiets effectivement
sur le risque que ces patients affectés
soient encore plus nombreux à l'hôpital
et qu'il de fait en raison bien sûr et
c'est là le problème de base en raison
du nombre limité de lits de réanimation
à disposition qu'il puisse altérer
l'offre de soins et que malheureusement
on soit obligé de reporter ou de
déprogrammer un certain nombre
d'activités chirurgicales non urgentes
ou d'activités médicales utile pour les
patients porteurs de maladies chroniques
alors malheureusement je n'ai pas de
communication directe avec le
gouvernement pour lui donner le moindre
conseil
d'ailleurs je ne me permettrais pas le
gouvernement est très probablement
entouré de personnes encore plus savante
que moi et encore plus expertes du sujet
je nous avons tout simplement souhaité
exprimer une opinion à nouveau qui n'a
qui n'a aucun but moralisateur mais
simplement d'information de la
population
il est temps évidemment que tout le
monde puisse comprendre et prendre sa
responsabilité
on fait appel au sens civique de chacun
d'entre nous philippe froguel vous
entendez bruno mega man qui nous dit au
fond et c'est vrai que nous sommes tous
concernés par l'évolution de cette
épidémie
oui mais entendu mais la peur n'évite
pas le danger
et j'ai un peu peur que par contre cette
tribune enfonce un peu des portes
ouvertes en disant qu'il faut porter le
masque oui effectivement faut porter le
masque et qu'il faut faire attention au
café et le porter réellement quand on a
pas on n'est pas en train de boire
justement sa tasse de café
certes tout à fait mais si c'était
suffisant on n'aurait pas treize mille
comptes personnes contaminées
aujourd'hui et le masque c'est un
retardateur c'est un petit peu comme
dans un fait un feu de forêt dans les
canadairs lance des des liquides sur la
forêt s'il n'ya pas emballé les pompiers
le feu s'arrête pas et on l'a bien vu
peut-être qu'on aurait 100 mille tonnes
d'eau contaminée par jour sans les
masques mais ça empêche pas de cette
augmentation donc il ya des choses qui
vont pas et ça c'est la chose importante
à faire et qui n'est pas proposée moi
personnellement je pense que l'europe
le gros trous dans la raquette qu'on a
depuis le début série de tests
à voir aujourd'hui dans la ville de
paris d'un test en 18 jours c'est ce1 et
copain m'a dit ça aujourd'hui c'est
inacceptable c'est totalement
inacceptable parce que ça sert à rien de
faire des tests on dépense énormément
d'argent pour plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros pour des tests qui ne
servent à rien aujourd'hui alors que ce
qu'il faut c'est monté des plateformes
pour faire des tests et des résultats en
une journée
là ça serait efficace bruno mes gamins
effectivement ce qu'on vient d'entendre
les propos de philippe froguel
est ce que votre tribune justement votre
signal d'alarmé d'un ce n'est pas la
preuve que
la stratégie du gouvernement a raté on
parlait des tests récemment on a testé
tester tester mais visiblement le
triptyque protéger tester isolé n'a pas
vraiment fonctionné alors j'irai je suis
d'accord avec les propos du professeur
froguel
donc effectivement les tests c'est
quelque chose de très important à mon
avis simplement il ne faut pas les
opposer au masque c'est complémentaire
et effectivement je ne peux pas dire que
la stratégie actuellement utilisé des
tests est optimale maintenant je ne
jetterai pas la pierre au ministre de la
santé non plus je crois qu'il fait au
mieux du possible
malgré tout il faut effectivement les là
je suis d'accord il faut optimiser les
tests en priorisant en introduisant là
où c'est possible des nouveaux tests
antigénique et salivaires pour permettre
évident a effectivement que ces tests
soient complémentaires au mieux pour le
masquer
mais malgré tout je ré insiste
effectivement le port du masque reste la
clé en fait si on portait de façon
satisfaisante le masque dans les bonnes
circonstances
eh bien on aurait aucune raison d'être
contaminés et donc aucune raison de
devoir faire des tests le problème c'est
que les gens malheureusement porte
relativement bien le masque dans les
supermarchés dans les moyens de
transport dans la rue là où l'intérêt
beaucoup plus limité et finalement
rentrer chez eux assistent à des soirées
entre amis ou des réunions familiales et
là comme par hasard en confiance parce
qu'effectivement ils sont avec des
personnes qu'ils connaissent
parfaitement enlève le masque et
risquent malheureusement de se
contaminer
c'est effectivement ces fameuses soirées
entre amis qu'il faut dans la mesure du
possible reporter et si elles doivent
être absolument organiser et bien il
maintenir la distanciation social où il
portait le masque notamment en présence
d'une personne plus âgée ou un risque
philippe royal avant de conclure
l'espoir viendra peut-être finalement du
nord puisqu'il ya du nouveau à
l'institut pasteur de lille est sur la
piste d'un médicament pour début 2011 21
qu'est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
philippe froguel alors nous a lille on
va faire deux choses sur les tests on va
ouvrir début août avoir une grande
plate-forme qui fera au minimum dix
mille tests par jour en moins de 24
heures on a va ouvrir le zénith de lille
pour ça donc ça ça va être une grande
première qu'on espère pouvoir faire
partout en france avec des partenaires
privés des laboratoires privés et
deuxièmement effectivement mon collègue
benoît déprez à un travail qui a débuté
vraiment très très tôt à 1 dès le mois
de mars à trouver une molécule qui est
une molécule connue qui est vendu déjà
pour d'autres choses qui a eu d'effets
secondaires connus ou même pas de
contenu et ce médicament qui est
générique et et bien dans les études
cellule à ce qu'on appelle et in vitro
des beaucoup beaucoup plus efficace
aller dos faible de la fameuse hydroxy
chloroquine marseillaise alors on en est
là et on essaie aujourd'hui de débuter
des études cliniques qui ne sont pas
faciles on l'a vu pour les tests
salivaires ça a été extrêmement
difficile de faire ses études sur les
tests salivaires qui sont pas encore
complètement terminé
et là on espère pour avoir ça dans les
dents les prochains mois et on espère
qu'il y aura une aide du gouvernement
mais aussi de nos collègues cliniciens
pour que l'on puisse tester ce
médicament à la seconde je suis
incapable de vous dire s'il sera
efficace médicalement il ya loin de la
coupe aux lèvres comme vous pouvez vous
en douter
et deuxièmement donnera pas le nom parce
que il ya eu l'expérience très
malheureuse hydroxyde qui s'est entendu
un grand merci en tout cas philippe
froguel je rappelle que vous êtes
généticien merci à vous bruno megaman
chef du service de réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière le caucase en
éruption une réunion d'urgence du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu est attendu
demain en jeu
le haut-karabakh un territoire que
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan se disputent
depuis trois décennies
les combats ont repris hier ils se sont
poursuivies ce matin plus de 550 soldats
arméniens auraient été tuées selon les
autorités azerbaïdjanaises
selon le ministre de la défense du haut
karabagh en revanche le bilan
s'élèverait à 58 victimes militaires
médiateur dans ce conflit qui dure
depuis plus de 30 ans la russie les
états unis ou encore la france
ils appellent tous à un cessez-le-feu
immédiat guilmard aussi des frappes
antichar qui pleuvent sur des blindées
azerbaïdjanais des images diffusées par
le ministère arménien de la défense mais
qui n'ont pas encore été authentifiée
par des sources indépendantes
depuis ce dimanche des combats opposent
l'armée azérie aux forces artsakh du
haut karabagh une région séparatiste de
l'azerbaïdjan soutenus par l'arménie
voisine
erevan a décrété la mobilisation
générale et la loi martiale
tout comme les autorités du haut
karabagh le premier ministre arménien
accuse l'azerbaïdjan d'avoir déclaré la
guerre à son peuple et appelle sa
population à se tenir prêtes à défendre
sa patrie sacrée
il s'agit d'une guerre imposée au peuple
arménien c'est une guerre contre notre
indépendance notre liberté et notre
dignité transit le peuple arménien était
préparé à l'éventualité d'une guerre car
nous savions que l'arménophobie
inimitiés et la haine avec lesquels la
dictature azerbaïdjanaise a nourri son
peuple pendant de nombreuses décennies
ne pouvait déboucher sur aucun autre
résultat que la guerre même ton
belliciste du côté de bakou a également
été décrété la loi martiale ainsi qu'un
couvre-feu l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
aurait repris plusieurs villages sous
contrôle arménien selon le ministère de
la défense
le président azéri a quant à lui assuré
son peuple de la victoire lors d'un
discours télévisé
les forces armées arméniennes ont tiré
sur nos colonies
ainsi que sur nos positions militaires
en utilisant diverses armes y compris de
l'artillerie lourde
depuis plusieurs directions l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise qui est actuellement sur
les positions militaires de lénine à la
suite de ces frappes
de nombreux équipements militaires de
l'ennemi ont été détruits
les combats auraient déjà fait plusieurs
victimes civiles et militaires selon les
deux belligérants qui se rejettent la
responsabilité de la reprise des
hostilités
sur ces images du centre d'information
unifié arménien à l'authenticité là
aussi incertaine des logements bombardé
à stepanakert la capitale du haut
karabagh le conflit entre l'azerbaïdjan
et l'arménie autour du haut karabagh
dure maintenant depuis plus de trente
ans les dames les affrontement remonte
au mois de juillet des combats
meurtriers au nord de la frontière avait
coûté la vie à une vingtaine de
personnes en quarts à moscou washington
paris nombreuses réactions
internationales concernant ce conflit
qui civile qui sévit au coeur du caucase
la correspondance en russie d'antoine
cléroux les combats continuent malgré
les nombreux appels au calme à la
retenue de plusieurs dirigeants les
états unis ou encore l'union européenne
ont appelé à la cessation immédiate des
hostilités la situation sur place a par
exemple été jugée très préoccupante par
le chef de la diplomatie européenne
josep borrell même son de cloche du côté
de l'elysée chacun connaît la proximité
de la france avec le peuple arménien il
doit retrouver la paix au plus vite la
france sera toujours à ses côtés
la france est prête à prendre toutes ses
responsabilités en tant que coprésidents
du groupe de minsk le président de la
république a appelé fermement à la
cessation immédiate des hostilités et
dit sa disponibilité à contribuer à un
règlement pacifique et durable de la
question du haut karabagh la russie qui
entretient de bonnes relations avec à la
fois l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan a offert
un rôle de médiateur et appelle elle
aussi au calme
région vous savez que la russie est
coprésidente du groupe de minsk de
l'osce ailleurs et bien sûr elle joue le
rôle de médiateur prêt à participer aux
résolutions
cette volonté a été mise en évidence à
différents niveaux
actuellement il est tout d'abord très
important de cesser les hostilités
au lieu de déterminer qui a tort et qui
a raison
la russie a toujours adopté une position
équilibrée ce qui lui permet d'utiliser
son influence et ses relations
traditionnellement bonnes avec les deux
pays
l'azerbaïdjan l'arménie afin de régler
le conflit
on l'a entendue dès dimanche l'arménie
et l'azerbaïdjan s'accusent mutuellement
d'avoir ouvert les hostilités
l'arménie qui a également saisi la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
demander des mesures provisoires contre
l'azerbaïdjan mais il est important de
souligner le rôle en coulisses d'un
autre acteur régional la turquie recep
tayyip erdogan a appelé ce lundi à la
fin de l'occupation arménienne du
karabagh allié de bakou de longue date
ankara l'a bien fait savoir qu'elle fera
tout ce qui est en son pouvoir pour les
venir en aide
sous-entendu même une intervention
militaire n'est pas exclue du jeu
condamne une fois de plus l'arménie qui
a attaqué le seul azerbaïdjanais a connu
la turquie continuera d'être aux côtés
de son ami et frère azerbaïdjanais par
tous les moyens et de tout son coeur sur
le dos le direct bob gainey dans le
crâne il est temps de mettre un terme à
la crise régionale qui a commencé avec
l'occupation du haut karabagh cinéma la
région atteindra à nouveau la paix et le
calme
avec le retrait immédiat de l'armée ni
de la terre azerbaïdjanaise qu'elle a
occupée
choisir tous les efforts de la
diplomatie internationale ne seront pas
de trop pour empêcher une guerre ouverte
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan une
guerre jusque là larvée depuis près de
30 ans un conflit aux enjeux locaux bien
entendu mais qui par procuration
pourrait déstabiliser bien plus que
cette région du monde et pour en parler
nous sommes avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
claude blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors vous
allez nous aider à y voir un peu plus
clair à la région séparatiste du haut
karabagh quels enjeux représente-t-elle
bah écoutez tout simplement la guerre et
la paix dans le caucase du sud
c'est une véritable bombe à retardement
que nous avons pris l'habitude d'appeler
depuis des années un conflit gelé mais
un conflit les jeunes et à un moment
donné
photographiant un rapport de force et ce
rapport de force peut se modifier dans
le temps et c'est probablement ce qui
est arrivé en effet le l'arménie et et
hélas verbal gens ont commencé à être en
conflit à la fin de l'époque soviétique
en 1988 et ce conflit a duré jusqu'en
1994 donc on était à l'époque de la
russie et la russie a réussi à négocier
à un cessez le feu en faisant une
médiation dans cette médiation
l'arménie a gagné à peu près 13 % du sol
un verbe et janet et maintenant c'est
l'armée arménienne qui compte pour le
cerf par sept partis y compris le
nagorny karabakh ni gros ni karabakh
c'est quoi et bien c'est un territoire
dans lequel vivent 150000 personnes qui
sont pour la plupart arménien en tout
cas ils sont de religion chrétienne et
obéissent au catholicos arménien et à
plusieurs reprises ils ont voulu être
rattachés à l'arménie en réalité pendant
cette guerre dont je viens de parler de
88 94
ils ont pris l'initiative de se déclarer
unilatéralement indépendant indépendance
reconnu par personne pas même par
l'arménie d'ailleurs donc on a là une
situation qui a duré gelé en 94 qui part
ce cessez le feu mais il ya en effet un
groupe de minsk dont on vient de parler
qui sous l'égide de l'eau et c'est eux
coprésidé par la russie par les états
unis par la france était supposé
conduire des négociations
ces négociations n'ont pas abouti et il
ya eu et physiquement des reprises du
conflit en 2016 et puis maintenant
depuis juillet et ce week-end dans des
conditions assez dramatique
alors il est possible en effet que en
laissant les conflits gelés trop
longtemps dans leur dans leur état
initial et bien au bout de 26 ans et ne
correspondent plus
au rapport de force et c'est ça qui est
inquiétant parce que l'azerbaïdjan est
un pays ayant de fortes ressources
pétrolières s'est beaucoup enrichi a
augmenté considérablement son budget
militaire aujourd'hui le budget
militaire de l'azerbaïdjan
c'est à peu près l'équivalent de la
totalité du budget annuel de l'arménie
donc un petit peu une disparité rapport
de forces est bien entendu cette
situation est préoccupante
l'azerbaïdjan cherche à chaque fois a
grignoté une partie du contrôle du
territoire contrôlé par par l'arménie
blanche maison en quelques mots la
russie évoqué comme médiateur mais
concrètement qu'elles roulent peut-elle
jouer
alors comme on vient de le dire la
turquie soutient le verbe est gens qui
appartient à la zone culturelle
turcophones et la russie a de bons
rapports avec les deux pays par
conséquent elle est tout désigné pour
mener une médiation en effet cela dit
l'arménie appartient aussi à
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective et se considère donc comme
défendue par la russie qui d'ailleurs a
une base militaire en arménie la russie
demande qu'il y ait un cessez le feu
tout le monde manqué un cessez-le-feu et
c'est en effet certainement la chose la
plus urgente
mais il faudrait que le groupe de minsk
encore une fois coprésidé par la russie
mais aussi par les etats-unis et par la
france reprenne son bâton de pèlerin
pour négocier un véritable accord merci
beaucoup
claude blanche maison pour votre
expertise rappelle que vous êtes expert
en relations internationales et vous
restez avec nous d'ailleurs car dans
quelques instants nous analyserons la
stature des manuels macron sur la scène
internationale est liban biélorussie
lituanie ces derniers jours le président
multiplie les prises de paroles et les
déplacements alors qu'elle voit le chef
de l'état donne t-il à la france dans le
monde
dans quel but on tente d'y répondre dans
quelques minutes
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter en partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche de l'intérêt de
leur population
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signé à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président entre hommes avaient décidé
de rompre l'accord et d'imposer son
régime de sanctions au niveau
international sur 1000 iran en grave
difficulté au plan économique et social
pour la chine c'est une très belle
opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parlement qui vote de grands objectifs
massif à peu à la manière des plans
quinquennaux soviétique le soutien à
l'éolien c'est entre 70 et 90 milliards
d'euros
la facture d'électricité des français va
forcément montech désormais ses financés
par les taxes qu'ils reportent sur le
carburant là les fameuses taxes
d'ailleurs qui ont provoqué la colère
des gilet jaune en fait isolé pour faire
de l'écologie est tombé assez difficile
d'expliquer aux gens que on laboure les
fonds marins ont détruit un écosystème
humain économique et tout ça pour le
bien de la planète
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française
emmanuel macron est en tournée de deux
jours à partir d'aujourd'hui en lituanie
et en lettonie est le chef de l'état va
rencontrer ses homologues des états
baltes le but évoqué la crise politique
en biélorussie il rencontrera demain
svetlana tirano sky à la figure de
l'opposition biélorusse a demandé au
président français de devenir un
médiateur dans le conflit qui l'oppose
au président alexandre loukachenko
monsieur macro est l'un des plus forts
leader en europe et dans le monde donc
il pourrait il pourrait être l'un de ces
médiateurs
peut-être qu'ils seraient capables
d'influencer monsieur poutine pour
participer à cette médiation car comme
je les ai entendus je sais qu'ils
entretiennent de bonnes relations avec
le président français qui s'est exprimé
hier sur la classe politique libanaise
avec des mots assez durs emmanuel macron
se posant en médiateur évoque une
trahison collective des dirigeants
libanais incapables de se mettre
d'accord après la démission du premier
ministre le pays continue de s'enfoncer
dans une grave crise sociale politique
et économique et la formation d'un
gouvernement semble compromise les
responsables politiques libanais ont
rendu impossible par leurs sombres
manoeuvres la formation d'un
gouvernement de mission capable de mener
à bien les réformes
certains ont d'abord préféré consolider
l'unité de leur camp plutôt que celle
des libanais dans leur ensemble les
autres ont cru pouvoir imposer les choix
de leur parti et du hezbollah dans la
formation du gouvernement en totale
contradiction avec les nécessités du
liban et avec les engagements
explicitement pris le 1er septembre
auprès de moi ils n'ont souhaité faire
aucune concession jusqu'au bout
le hezbollah ne peut en même temps être
une armée en guerre contre israël
une milice déchaînée contre les civils
en syrie est un parti respectable au
liban il ne doit pas se croire plus fort
qu'il ne l'est et c'est à lui de
démontrer qu'ils respectent les libanais
dans leur ensemble ils à ces derniers
jours clairement montré le contraire
alors lituanie biélorussie liban
emmanuel macron est sur tous les fronts
alors qu'est-ce que les dernières prises
de parole du président à l'international
révèlent à quel est sa stature sur la
scène mondiale qu'elle voit le chef de
l'état entend t-il donné à la france
dans le monde
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage et
pour en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain éditorialistes bonsoir à vos
côtés françois el bacha économiste et
fondateur de libnanews bonsoir et nous a
rejoint également claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
rebond square claude blanche maison
alors messieurs on a on a donc entendu
un ces dernières heures les mots engagés
du président français sur la scène
internationale tout d'abord à propos du
liban où il a dit avoir honte pour les
dirigeants libanais concernant le
dossier biélorussie l'a affirmé il est
clair que loukachenko doit partir alors
claude blanche maison je me tourne vers
vous emmanuel macron comme médiateur
c'est aussi la volonté de l'opposante
bébé la rustique anoska ya une rencontre
est prévue demain entre les deux
emmanuel macron a déjà tranché lui le
président biélorusse lukashenko tu dois
partir
dans ce contexte le terme médiateur est
il approprié finalement alors évidemment
c'est très difficile d'abord pourra dire
que emmanuel macron a entrepris de
rendre visite à à tous les pays membres
de l'union européenne qu'ils soient
grands ou petits et que d'ailleurs il
n'ya pas de petits pays dans l'union
européenne puisque chacun a une voix au
conseil européen et peut s'opposer à une
décision chacun a un droit de veto
alors il se trouve que là il va
rencontrer l'opposante
et le russe puisque c'est un pays voisin
d'ailleurs voisin de la biélorussie mais
aussi voisin de kaliningrad est une
enclave russe à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne
donc il va évoquer les problèmes de
sécurité avec les autorités de la
lituanie puis la lettonie
et puis il va écouter ce que madame
cette lan à petit canot sera à lui dire
ce qu'il a à lui dire demain matin et il
est probable qu'on ait fait elle va
réitérer ce qu'elle a dit hier au
journal du dimanche à savoir une demande
qu'ils participent à une médiation sous
une forme ou sous une autre médiation ou
ou facilitation pour trouver une
solution
elle même dit qu'il doit user de ses
bonnes relations avec monsieur poutine
puisque l'opposition à leucan tchenko
pour le moment n'a à aucun moment émis
des opinions anti russe elle dit la
russie et notre voisine et nous voulons
avoir de bons rapports avec la russie
donc c'est une situation tout à fait
particulière et très clairement affirmée
alors je pense que personne ne peut être
le médiateur sans doute monsieur macron
proposera t-il à madame d'ikanos callas
d'en parler bien sûr aux autres
dirigeants européens puisqu'il y à jeudi
et vendredi un conseil européen à
bruxelles il en parlera certainement
avant même cela à madame angela merkel
et pour voir dans quelle mesure
l'union européenne peut aider à trouver
une solution il en portera certainement
aussi au téléphone avec vladimir poutine
comme il l'a déjà fait je noterai aussi
que madame chicanos callas considère que
des sanctions économiques ne sont pas
appropriés parce que dans le fond ça se
retournerait contre la population
devienne russie et que dans cette
affaire il s'agit de défendre la
population de biélorussie et de voir
comment en effet faire en sorte que
dictateur biélorusse ce dernier
dictateur en europe finissent par céder
la place à un régime plus plus
démocratique en tout cas qui
correspondent aux besoins du moment en
biélorussie alors alexis poulain pendant
ce temps il ya un contexte de crise
sanitaire et économique qui est lourd en
france
est ce que vous comprenez de sept
volumes volonté du président français de
vouloir endosser le rôle de médiateur à
l'international c'est un peu facile pour
émuler le maquereau aujourd'hui ce qu'il
fait c'est qu'il est présent
effectivement sur tous les fronts mais
certainement pas à domicile on a
l'impression qu'il préfère parler du
liban plutôt que de parler de son bilan
parce que aujourd'hui en france les
français eux parlent de la crise du
grenat virus
les commerçants à marseille mais
ailleurs ont peur d'un nouveau
confinement de la fermeture de leur
commerce de manière totalement
disproportionnées par rapport à la crise
sanitaire que nous vivons or emmanuel
macron a décidé de sensibiliser de la
scène nationale et d'exister à
l'international parce que c'est là qu'il
va pouvoir se refaire une stature de
présidentiable
pour 2022 et évidemment c'est
extrêmement facile ça lui permet
d'échapper à la critique puisque là sur
la scène internationale il est respecté
en tant que président d'un pays qui est
la france est encore un pays respecté
dans les relations internationales
la preuve en est madame chicanos kaya
qui lui demande d'être médiateur légal
de la russie dans la crise biélorusse le
liban là par contre c'est un peu plus
compliqué on voit bien que la parole des
malades macron n'a pas été du tout
respecté ou prise en compte par les
parties en présence au liban qui décide
de faire comme à l'habitude et c'est à
dire de s'arranger entre eux à la façon
d'avancer macron n'a aucun mandat sur le
liban il faudrait peut-être un mandat
international d'autre chose mais la
france ne pèse pas comme il était le cas
avant on n'est plus dans un monde
colonial de protectorat ou autre il
faudrait qu'elle manquerait se mettre à
jour donc pour lui c'est tout bénéfice
en fait de manière politique pour se
réinventer refaire une image se
reprendre un peu de la hauteur et c'est
ce que fait me les maquereaux
aujourd'hui françois el bacha lexsi
poulain parlait du liban à l'instant de
cette prise de parole adressée aux
dirigeants libanais
avec des mots durs je vous propose de
regarder et puis on vous entend après
françois el bacha les forces politiques
libanaises leurs dirigeants les
dirigeants des institutions libanaises
n'ont pas souhaité clairement résolument
explicitement n'ont pas souhaité
respecter l'engagement pris devant la
france et la communauté internationale
ils ont décidé et je suis contraint d'en
faire le constat cruel pour nous tous un
mois plus tard ils ont décidé de trahir
cet engagement pris alors françois el
bacha comment cette prise de parole at
elle été reçue par la population est ce
que c'est ce que souhaitait entendre les
libanais au fond les libanais ils sont
fatigués des partis politiques
donc oui plus on fait la pression sur
les partis politiques à +6 apprécié le
problème aujourd'hui est qu'on a besoin
le problème de base c'est qu'on a un
dysfonctionnement structurel au liban le
liban ne peut pas fonctionner depuis les
accords de thérèse sans ingérence
étrangère
tout simplement il faut des parents à
chaque fois et on a eu on est le parrain
américain on a le parrain iranien on à
la turquie de rentrer dans le jeu et on
espère une ingérence bienveillante qui
puisse changer le système
parce qu'on ne peut pas changer le
système par nous-mêmes et libanais n'ont
pas les moyens de changer le système par
eux-mêmes tout simplement à cause de
toutes ces ingérences
donc effectivement le d'un point de vue
beaucoup de gens sont assez favorables à
cette ingérence la 6è les bienveillantes
aller alexis poulain est vide et
effectivement ce mot ingérence on l'a
entendu aussi en france avec des
réactions nombreuses notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux
et puis beaucoup se sont en parallèle
interrogé sur la vivacité du président
français tout en ôtant son silence sur
les dossiers français cela vous a étonné
aussi
alix poulain non c'est effectivement
tout le monde a bien vu que quand on est
mené le maquereau ou parler du liban
c'était un peu comme dans ce film de
pagnol
la femme du boulanger ou le boulanger
s'adresse à la chatte qui est partie
pour finalement s'adresser à sa femme
donc emmanuel macron parler du liban
pour parler de la france à ceux qui
voulaient bloquer la situation à ceux
qui ne voulaient pas d'unité nationale
on sentait très bien que derrière cette
situation libanaise
il avait en écho sa situation
personnelle et l'état français
donc ça c'était un peu déplacé par
rapport à la crise libanaise et puis un
fait est que emmanuel macron a sans
doute présumé de ses forces et de sa
stature pour aller directement au liban
et s'imposer comme médiateur
quel est son mandat quel est aujourd'hui
le mandat international qui permettrait
de mettre tout le monde autour de la
table et de réunir bien il ya un
président au liban michel aoun qui doit
trouver un nouveau premier ministre
puisqu'il ya un premier ministre
démissionnaire et remettre les partis
autour de la table ou bien refaire des
élections revoir une chose mais quel est
le rôle du président français dans cette
affaire là à part de dire que oui la
france est bien tend la main au peuple
libanais essaye de faire des choses et
même macron là encore une fois fait un
peu comme il a l'habitude c'est à dire
qu'il se lance dans des aventures sans
avoir les moyens finalement de voir là
où ça en med tout un pays tout une
diplomatie et ça c'est extrêmement
dangereuse c'est extrêmement volatile et
j'espère que dans la sphère de leca
biélorusse on va pas se retrouver dans
une même impasse ce n'est pas à
souhaiter
sachant que emma le maquereau bien sûr
garde le dialogue ouvert avec avec la
russie ça c'est extrêmement important
dans cette danse dans ce cas là pour le
liban c'est autre chose on a vu le
hesbollah la façon dont il a admonesté
georges malbrunot qui avait soi disant
sorti des informations qu'il n'aurait
pas dû excusez moi mais un journaliste
re son métier c'est de sortir des
informations pour que les gens soient
informés
il n'a pas s'arrêter là où commence la
diplomatie ou l'intérêt du chef de
l'état donc une leçon apprise
espérons que celle-ci aura porté ses
fruits dans les autres affaires
internationales dans lesquels emmanuel
macron va s'impliquer claude blanche
saison on vous a vu sourire quand alexis
poulain d'isaac emmanuel macron vous
l'êtes aussi à parler à la france quand
il s'exprimait devant le peuple libanais
est ce que effectivement
diplomatiquement il peut y avoir des
messages subliminaux finalement je crois
que emmanuel macron a décidé
d'abandonner le langage diplomatique
feutray pour dire carrément tout ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent tout bas
et c'est le cas dans la sphère libanaise
c'est ce que on a dit d'ailleurs aussi
tout à l'heure alors bien sûr ça peut
choquer parce qu'après tout le liban un
gouvernement on peut penser ce qu'on
veut de ce gouvernement mais c'est le
gouvernement du liban et il est probable
que ce gouvernement et les élites
libanais est ont pas été très heureux
d'entendre ce qu'elles ont entendu hier
mais cela dit tactiquement macron en
faisant cela a pris une posture qui sur
la scène internationale est une posture
intéressante c'est à dire qu'il a la
main sur les flux d'air il a dit très
clairement aurait vite et aux hauts
dirigeants libanais je m'opposerai à
l'aide de l'union européenne je
m'opposerai à l'aide internationale
à l'aide du fmi si vous continuez comme
ça donc les dirigeants sont au pied du
mur
apparemment ils sont assez intéressés
par ces flux financiers
et bien il y aura pas de flux financiers
dead tant pis si le régime libanais
continue comme il l'a fait auparavant
et s'il ya un risque de détournement de
cette aide internationale
alors effectivement si le gouvernement
libanais acceptent qui vieillit à une
organisation de l'onu des ong qui
garantissent que ces fonds ne pourrait
pas ne pourront pas détournés et qu'ils
iront effectivement à l'éducation de la
population à la santé de la population à
la construction des infrastructures
il pourra y avoir une aide et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'il a qui l'a répété
qu'il souhaitait réunir les bailleurs de
fonds avant la fin du mois d'octobre
mais il a la main sur le robinet de
l'aide françois el bacha on se souvient
emmanuel macron avait lancé un ultimatum
aux dirigeants lee
mais pour qu'il forme un gouvernement
rapidement ils ne l'ont pas fait comment
est ce que les dirigeants libanais
perçoivent le président français
aujourd'hui
ici comme à 10 précédemment
monsieur maison les les dirigeants
libanais sont très intéressés par led
économes look donc et ils ont été
pendant longtemps des bénéficiaires par
exemple des programmes européens de
gestion des ordures qui ont coûté 160 5
millions de dollars financés par
l'europe et 50% de ces sommes ont été
surfacturés et les bénéficiaires sont
des sociétés appartenant à des hommes
politiques
ça c'est un fait fermer cette vanne et
ben c'est un peu les asphyxier aussi
mais ils ont transféré cet argent à
l'étranger
c'est là et c'est pas des dirigeants
politiques en fin de course est dédiée
ce et des chefs d'entreprise qui ont
détourné tout un système économique mise
en place et toute une masse tout un
système mafieux mise en place du temps
de la syrie à leurs propres bénéfices
quand la syrie s'est retirée du liban
c'est très simple et maintenant qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui s'intéresse de nouveau au
liban
en même temps ils sont intéressés il ya
le yahia la carotte et en même temps il
ya le bâton ils n'auront pas accès à
cette aide
tout simplement alors alex ivoula on
vous a entendu assez critique sur la
posture à l'international du chef de
l'état vous en attendez quoi vous
aujourd'hui du du président emmanuel
macron sur cette posture selon vous
qu'il devrait avoir
aujourd'hui à l'international notamment
sur le dossier libanais et
le dossier biélorusse sur le dossier
libanais la france ne peut pas y aller
seul en réalité c'est quel est le mandat
international
aujourd'hui qui va remettre les
responsables politiques autour de la
table et qui va faire que le peuple
libanais ne va pas être encore une fois
victime des intérêts privés de quelques
partis qui effectivement ont capté les
richesses sur les autres dossiers
internationaux j'espère qu'il y aura de
la prudence parce que ce qu'on voit avec
emmanuel macron souvent c'est beaucoup
d' aventure
ces quelques coups de poker et
malheureusement aujourd'hui la france
n'a pas forcément les moyens de ses
ambitions il faut voir que dans
certaines crises il faudrait peut-être
un peu plus réaliste et s'appuyer sur
des alliés et ne pas avoir une position
forcément atlantiste ou autres parce que
aujourd'hui l'union européenne un
problème à résoudre deux disons d'abord
la crise migratoire aujourd'hui
clairement non résolus et puis la crise
sanitaire celle du commis de 19 et on
voit bien qu'un peu partout dans les
pays européens france allemagne belgique
et autres biens cette crise n'est
certainement pas résolu donc vouloir
ouvrir de nouveaux fronts aujourd'hui à
l'international en pensant que nous
sommes en position de force
c'est pour moi une grave erreur qui
pourrait coûter cher notamment à la
france dans les années à venir après
emmanuel macron parce qu'il y aura un
après claude blanchou maison est ce que
cette posture pourrait coûter cher à la
france dans les années à venir comme le
souligne alex à l'instant alexis poulain
selon vous je crois que tout chef de
l'état français quel qu'il soit et
chacun avec sa femme anne hier et est
préoccupé naturellement par ce qui se
passe dans les pays voisins par la paix
et la sécurité
et pour ça bon on est d'accord on n'est
pas d'accord mais à l'union européenne
et au delà de l'union européenne
il est préoccupé par ce qui se passe
dans les pays environnants et ce qui se
passe en méditerranée fait partie de cet
environnement
alors c'est vrai que il est légitime que
un chef d'état français se préoccupe de
la paix de la stabilité en biélorussie
or elle n'est plus assurée aujourd'hui
avec un président contesté comme les
monsieur loukachenko par conséquent et
il est
il doit en effet avec en effet les
autres partenaires européens avec le
chef de l'état russe avec la dîmière
poutine se préoccuper des lavaur est un
processus de transition en biélorussie
et de la même manière d'élaborer un
processus de transition en au liban
parce que la situation actuelle
d'abord le peuple libanais souffre
puisqu'il ya un appauvrissement
considérable du peuple libanais mais
c'est une situation potentiellement
explosive est très dangereuse pour la
stabilité de la région
donc je crois que encore une fois quel
que soit les présidents futur de la
france ils auront une préoccupation du
même du même style du même genre
le mot de la fin pour conclure françois
el bacha qu'est ce que vous attendez du
président français qu'est ce que le
liban en tout cas attendue du président
français à court et moyen terme
à court terme une f les réserves
monétaires qui servent à subventionner
les produits de première nécessité
seront épuisées d'ici un an et demi
maintenant ça veut dire que d'ici un an
et demi on aura ou une paupérisation
accélérée parce qu'on ne doit avoir une
dévaluation de facto plus important de
la libanaise ou des troubles sociaux
économiques considérables donc emmanuel
macron là dessus a raison sur son
inventaire de la situation
ça c'est un moyen terme on n'a pas de
vue strictement économique quand il a
parlé des banques et du système bancaire
en particulier il a eu raison
c'est quelque chose que que certains
cercles disait depuis longtemps il y a
les partis ne sont pas seulement des
partis politiques ce sont des personnes
qui sont proches des milieux d'affaires
et qui ont détourné d'énormes sommes à
partir de ces de la dette à partir tout
simplement
donc s'il ya une pression internationale
une ingérence bienveillante honoraires
le liban a plus à gagner qu'à perdre
tout simplement on a brûlé beaucoup d'
ingérence qui ont étaient nocives les
ingérences américaines
les ingérences trade and agences
iraniennes et ainsi de suite hélas si on
a une ingérence positive la france a
aussi à y gagner parce qu'il ya des
histoires d'hydrocarbures au large des
côtes mais aussi à 25 millions de
migrants syriens présents au liban qui
peuvent ensuite déferlé sur l'europe
donc ça peut être du donnant donnant pas
on peut avoir une ingérence positif sur
le lit branche simplement un grand merci
à tous les trois d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci à vous françois el bacha
je rappelle que vous êtes économiste
fondateur de libnanews merci avons
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
merci à vous alexis poulain je rappelle
que vous êtes éditorialistes et dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
le plan de relance de la france 42 des
100 milliards d'euros seront dépensés
avant la fin de l'année prochaine
explique le ministre de l'économie puis
nous parlerons de cette proposition du
garde des sceaux eric dupond moretti
il plaide pour une justice totalement
filmés et diffusés jusqu'ici réservées
aux seuls procès d' historique
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dans des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement
oui j'ai un macbook ou de vanille
2 cd pourquoi aujourd'hui le président
et candidat à sa propre succession
nous estimons que l'opposant ouattara
est celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face ont pu fiction posent à
nous tant au niveau interne ou externe
un climat particulier en ce moment en
côte d'ivoire et des violences sous
prétexte donc une manifestation et
d'expression de droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on est si comme eux
tu es ce que sincèrement vous êtes
certains que le scrutin du 31 octobre
sera maintenu à la date prévue
mais il n'y a pas des raisons plus ce
scrutin ne soit pas maintenu
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et l'infante allant de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend telles
valeurs on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral débats éthiques
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président entre hommes vais décider
de rompre l'accord et d'imposer son
régime de sanctions au niveau
international sur 1000 iran en grave
difficulté au plan économique et social
pour la chine c'est une très belle
opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
un président un brésilien g1 max hoarau
ni la gravité de la pandémie il a été
élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaître nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
et
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
oh
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois dans les banques où la diversité
c'est notre point fort pas l'autre point
faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs a
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
et finalement tu mon discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois voyez des images assez
touchants de l'armée qui était presque
impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause des hommes politiques et
sont en train de manipuler l'armée on
sait très bien pourquoi ils nous tirent
dessus sais pas s'ils savent que c'est
leur fin ils se préparent le seul
langage qu'ils connaissaient la violence
il ne va pas être violent mais on va
rester
et il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
c'est voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 28 septembre 2020 en france 42
des 100 milliards d'euros du plan de
relance seront dépensés avant la fin de
l'année prochaine l annonce a été faite
à la mi journée par bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie défend un budget
2021 je cite qui répondre à l'urgence
face à la crise sanitaire et économique
est la commission des comptes prévoit
elle à 44,7 milliards d'euros de déficit
en 2020 pour la sécurité sociale
c'est moins que prévu une justice
totalement filmés et diffusés eric
dupond-moretti l'appelle de ses voeux
une proposition du garde des sceaux
avec pour objectif de montrer la
complexité des cas traités et améliorer
la compréhension des décisions de
justice
alors faut-il film est diffusé tous les
procès ne faut-il pas réservé
l'enregistrement vidéo à des procès
estimé historique
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
aux etats unis j moins un avant le débat
donald trump et joe biden vont en
découdre à la télévision avant le
scrutin présidentiel américain du 3
novembre une campagne marquée par la
révélation du new york times le
président des états unis n'aurait payé
que 750 dollars d'impôts l'année de son
élection
[Musique]
la situation sanitaire en france à
présent et les derniers chiffres de
santé public français l'agent s'annonce
plus de 12000 nouvelles contaminations
que 8,19 en 24 heures quatre-vingt-une
personnes se sont décédées à l'hôpital
et 780 patients sont actuellement en
réanimation et les mesures prises pour
contrer l'épidémie suscite de la colère
une centaine de professionnels de la
restauration ont bloqué tout à l'heure
un tunnel à marseille pour manifester
contre la fermeture des bars et
restaurants sur la canebière pour 15
jours à paris et dans les villes
classées alerte renforcée les bars
fermeront à partir de 22h ce soir et
c'est le cas à bordeaux lille ou encore
à lyon où le maire écologiste grigori
doucet se montre critique envers les
récentes annonces gouvernementales liées
à la situation sanitaire
j'appelle véritablement de mes voeux une
politique de réponse une politique
sanitaire qui qu'ils fassent davantage
appel fait qu'ils recherchent davantage
l'adhésion il me semble que les
dernières annonces au contraire créer
plutôt de la division et danser dans
cette de ce moment de rebond ça ne me
semble pas être la bonne stratégie et à
paris comment cela se passait bien on va
retrouver notre reporter nadège
abderrazak dans les rues de la capitale
aux abords de la place de la bastille
bonsoir nadège alors un peu moins de
deux heures de la fermeture des bars
quelle est l'atmosphère autour de vous
bah écoutez olivier les parisiens vont
devoir écourter leur fin de soirée un
puisque effectivement dans moins d'une
heure elle et bars de la capitale sont
invités bien a baissé les rideaux fou
donc au dans ce quartier de la bastille
on a eu pas mal de monde quand même qui
est bien profitent des derniers barres
2d dernier bar ouvert dès de boire le
dernier dernier vers 2 de la soirée 1
puisque effectivement après des
négociations avec la mairie de paris la
préfecture de police est bien a décidé
de fermer à partir de 22 heures tous les
bars de la capitale
tous les établissements je cite qui
pratiquent la vente de boissons
alcoolisées à titre principal cette
mesure exclut donc les restaurants qui
vont pouvoir bien rester ouvert et
servir eux-mêmes de l'alcool en
accompagnement d'un repas de nombreux
gérants de bars et bien accuse le coup
et déplore un manque à gagner important
écouter on est un restaurant donc on a
la chance de rester jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin ouvert mais après notre chiffre
d'affaires s'est fait beau pour la nuit
et grâce aux babouins sont donc à partir
de 22 heures ça va quand même un peu
changé pour nous et
on va continuer à être ouverte on va
pouvoir travailler mais de toute façon
on trouve qu'elle avait sur elle est un
peu bas
incohérente pasquier ba les mureaux ccva
la toux la journée pourquoi nous
pourquoi pas les cinémas les transports
en commun et ses droits ou à beaucoup
plus de monde
même son de cloche du côté des parisiens
qui qualifie d' incohérente
cette fermeture des bars à partir de 22
heures je comprends pas pourquoi parce
que de toutes façons de temps en temps
c'est l' angoisse totale d'autres fois
il ya certains qui rassure qui disent
non bon c'est un peu incompréhensible en
tout cas moi je comprends que les jeunes
n'ai pas envie que je n'ai pas envie de
vivre comme ça moi je trouve que c'est
pas très cohérent en fait aucune des
mesures qui ont été prises mais grunge
et rouge parce qu'à basket déjà été dit
je dire moi j'ai pris le métro hier
avant-hier il ya plein de monde dans le
métro il n'ya pas il ya plus du tout de
distance à sion on est assis les uns à
côté des autres c'est pareil dans le
train ces anneaux coupe notre liberté
c'est surtout ça déjà rien que le port
du masque bien sûr c'est le respect de
l'autre mais où est toute liberté
la préfecture de police de paris a
prévenu que les contrôles allaient être
renforcées en cas de non-respect lé
gérant de bar s'exposent à des amendes
record des amendes de fortes amendes à
une fermeture forcée de leur
établissement ou encore à des peines de
prison avec sursis les contrevenants de
leur côté pourraient être verbalisés ces
restrictions vont être mises en place
durant 15 jours d'ici au 12 octobre
prochain les autorités vont de nouveau
réévalué la situation pourrait bien
estimer s'il est nécessaire de continuer
ou d'arrêter
les mesures mises en place merci
beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions on a déjà des razak en direct
de paris à proximité de la place de la
bastille à un peu moins d'une heure
maintenant de la fermeture des bars
liées à la crise du coronavirus et après
460 milliards d'euros cette année pour
faire face justement la crise sanitaire
place à un budget 2021 centré sur le
plan de relance sur les 100 milliards de
ce bi 6,42 seront dépensés avant fin
2021 22 milliards de crédits de paiement
pour l'investissement public à 10
milliards de baisses d'impôts de
production et 10 milliards devant être
dépensés avant la fin de l'année 2020 un
programme sur deux ans donc avec la
volonté de décaisser le plus vite
possible pour avoir l'impact le plus
rapide possible
ce sont les mots du ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire et pour parler
de la situation et économique dans le
sillage de la crise justement nous
sommes avec philippe herlin économiste
philippe herlin merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors pour
débuter je vous propose de nous arrêter
sur la situation des dirigeants de bars
et des restaurants après la fermeture
totale ou à 22 heures annoncées certains
ne parviendront pas à passer cette
nouvelle étape le métier et il sacrifié
sur l'autel de la santé finalement oui
je pense parce que surtout que cette
décision de fermer à 22h est assez
incompréhensible
comme si les circuler jusqu à 21h59
et puis ensuite il devenait virulent à
22h donc par équipes qui est
incompréhensible et qui va planter
vraiment de ddd des restaurants et des
bars qui sont ce qu'ils sont des
indépendants l'incomparable qu'un c'est
à dire des gens qui n'ont pas les
épaules solides
c'est pas comme les chaînes les grandes
chaînes de distribution ou de vente de
vêtements qui sont des grands groupes
qui peuvent encaisser un choc de cette
nature là sont les indépendants et
s'extrait ça va être extrêmement
difficile pour eux et je trouve vraiment
critiquable c'est cette décision du
gouvernement qui correspond pas à grand
chose en plus formation que olivier
viron veut régler des comptes personnels
parce qu'il faut quand même se rendre
compte que au départ il était prévu que
toute la métropole de marseille et d'aix
voit ses restaurants et ses bars fermés
et finalement il ya qu'eux
sèye et excès et pas les 98 mais deux
villes qui composent celle d'être
opposant pas impressionné rang avec ses
comptes avec le docteur house et avec la
maire d'aix qui la lui a demandé de la
fermer
voilà donc ça y'a pas plus voilà et donc
et pour paris aussi voilà c'est une
décision incompréhensible donc ils
peuvent peser lourdement sur les comptes
de ces entreprises qui vont tous et
beaucoup à la faillite
il était déjà 2000 fleuriste qui ont
fait faillite ça représente
amaury 15% de la totalité des fleuristes
de france voilà on est au début et pour
les bars et les restaurants on va avoir
des chiffres de ce niveau là et ça va
être catastrophique pour l'économie
parce que concernant justement la la
baisse du chiffre d'affaires dans ces
établissements l'île de france accuse la
plus forte chute selon une étude
dévoilée par le parisien il va y avoir
donc de grandes disparités régionales
c'est à lire le livre de france et
surtout paris comptait aussi fonctionner
aussi beaucoup avec le tourisme il faut
le comprendre ainsi ainsi que les dix
villes du sud d'ailleurs et elles n'ont
pas aussi de touristes cet été donc déjà
c'est un coup très dur lieu confinement
on le sait est là en plus cette
fermeture ça va être le coup de grâce
pour beaucoup qui pouvait espérer s'en
sortir avec une rentrée qui aurait pu
bien se passer de paix malheureusement
ce n'est pas le cas et on voit que c'est
c'est pas le cas pour le restaurant mais
c'est aussi pas le cas par an pour les
salles où on vient d'apprendre à
l'instant que selon des patrimoines
culturels qui si un appareil à 1300
exposants étaient annulés il ya paris
photo la fia qui sont en éveil à la
foire de paris la foire de marseille
tout ça c'est énormément d'activités de
rencontres qui sont qui sont annulées et
ça va peser sur l'économie et sur et sur
la reprise et c'est vraiment malheureux
de constater alors justement pour
pallier à cette crise économique
le projet du budget présenté ce lundi
matin en conseil des ministres prévoit
des émissions de dette record afin de
financer le plan de relance et le
maintien d'un déficit très élevés en
est ce que c'est le grand plongeon
nécessaire selon vous non non je sais
pas un plan c'est pas le bon plan parce
que la relance soutenue par les dépenses
gouvernement c est ce que la france fait
depuis 1975 date à partir de laquelle on
est difficile
budget ont commencé depuis cette date on
fait un début difficile en ne nous
expliquant que c'est pour soutenir
l'activité économique
et on voit résultats c'est à dire une
croissance qui s'affaiblit de décennie
en décennie déjà avoir le qu'ovide on a
vu une croissance faible et donc la c3
lance la sas et servira à rien ça
provoque un pas de croissance la seule
bonne chose qui leur a fallu faire c'est
une baisse d'impôts lors il y en a un
petit peu dans dans le plan il faut le
dire il ya une baisse d'impôts de
production et ça c'est une très bonne
chose que ça pèse lourdement sur les
entreprises notamment industrielles mais
je pense qu'il aurait fallu privilégier
les baisses d'impôts parce que en
distribuant des crédits et les
subventions
on va aider aussi bien les entreprises
qui sont structurellement rentable et
qui ont juste eu un coup dur ep
confinement que les entreprises qui sont
qui était déjà malade avant le
confinement cécile bergame avoir ce
qu'on appelle en économie des
entreprises zombies salers d'entreprise
qui qui qui sont pas en situation d'être
rentable dès qu'ils sont soutenus par du
crédit et par des aides étatiques et ça
c'est très mauvais parce que ces
entreprises là bas ils prennent la place
de nouvelles on dope risque qui serait
plus rentable et plus efficace qu'elle
philippe herlin je vais reprendre les
mots de bruno le maire la dette c'est de
l'investissement mais il faudra le
rembourser ce qu'il a martelé le
ministre des finances tout en faisant le
choix vous le rappeler il ya quelques
instants de poursuivre la baisse des
impôts mais c'est possible ou pas
finalement à la fois de rembourser de
devoir rembourser la dette tout en
baissant les impôts alors pour baisser
les impôts il faut pas seulement
s'endetter ce qui peut se comprendre la
crise actuelle il faut aussi faire une
réforme de l'état et baisser la dépense
publique parce que la france a des
dépenses que ligue qui sont vraiment
énormes qui sont les plus importants des
pays de céder donc on ne peut pas
espérer baisser les impôts de façon
saine si on sent que c'est pas de
réforme structurelle de l'état et ça
c'était complètement abandonné par un
par le gouvernement et ses sites dommage
voilà ce qu'à 26 ans et pacifiquement
des suivantes pendant tel type de
réformes structurelles
aurait pu être mis en place par exemple
on va pendant les heures de la santé on
a vu l'hôpital public a eu du mal à
absorber tous les nouveaux tous les
nouveaux malades du candidat à côté de
ça il y avait des cliniques privées
qu'avec des places libres on les a pas
utilisés tant qu'il ya un problème de
coordination moi je pense qu'il faudrait
aller vers une privatisation d'un grand
nombre les grandes parties de l'hôpital
public
et puis pour faire des économies c'est
très simple on peut supprimer les ars
agences régionales de santé qui ne
servent à rien et on a vu et pendant la
crise quelles qu'elles n'étaient
uniquement une couche d'euros cratique
qui ralentissaient les choses et qui
donnait des ordres contradictoires dont
l'adoption supprimer des ars entre les
économies et on rendrait les hôpitaux
plus efficace voilà c'est un exemple
parmi d'autres médias il ya des réformes
à faire maintenant
merci beaucoup philippe herlin d'avoir
partagé votre éclairage rappelle que
vous êtes économistes et après les
entreprises et les hôpitaux les écoles
et les nuls et les universités sont les
principaux foyers de contamination en
france malgré des chiffres inquiétants
le gouvernement ne souhaite pas la
fermeture des établissements ayant eu
des cas de covile 19
il ya une semaine deux mille classes et
90 établissements avaient dû fermer
quelques jours plus tard le ministre de
l'éducation avait annoncé leur
réouverture regarder selon une étude
santé publique france les collectivités
majoritairement responsables de la
transmission du coc vite dans l'hexagone
sont désormais les milieux scolaires et
les universitaires sur 899 cluster en
cours d'investigation au 24 septembre
on comptabilise 200 85 écoles ou
universités soit un tiers des clusters
actifs
mais ce qui alarme le plus ce n'est pas
le nombre de foyers mais plutôt leur
révolution
6 160 foyers de contamination ont été
détectés le 17 septembre seulement une
semaine avant ce nombre n'était que de
26 malgré ces résultats le gouvernement
se veut rassurant et insiste sur les
chiffres encourageants liés à ces
nouveaux foyers de contamination majeur
au 19 septembre 2000 classé 90
établissements avaient dû fermer
ils semaine après jean michel blanquer
air annoncé la réouverture de près de
850 classe est de plus de soixante dix
établissements et décision encouragée
par les dépistage massif qui ont permis
de révéler 5612 dépistés positifs sur
plus de 12 millions d'élèves et 1153
pour les enseignants est toujours en
france cette proposition du garde des
sceaux de rendre publics les audiences
eric dupond moretti se prononce en
faveur d'une justice totalement filmés
et diffusés comme il l'a confié à nos
confrères du parisien ce dimanche le
ministre de la justice qui voit une
garantie démocratique et souhaiterait
porter cela avant la fin du quinquennat
en france
l'enregistrement vidéo est autorisé
depuis 1985 mais seulement pour des
procès à dimension historique comme
celui des attentats 2015 qui a lieu en
ce moment alors cette proposition du
garde des sceaux faut-il filmer ou
diffuser tous les procès cela peut-il
donner aux français une meilleure
lisibilité du système judiciaire c'est
l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
florence rault avocate pénaliste bonsoir
à vos côtés vincent berger avocat
spécialiste de droit international
alors avant de vous donner la parole je
vous propose de regarder un ce tweet
d'eric dupond-moretti
je suis pour que la justice soit
désormais totalement filmer et diffuser
la justice doit se montrer aux français
la publicité des débats est une garantie
démocratique alors la publicité des
débats est une garantie démocratique et
riz écrit par don eric dupond-moretti
alors est ce que le ministre de la
justice a raison est ce que la justice
doit s'ouvrir pour faire de la pédagogie
selon vous florence rault le ministre de
la justice nous dit que la justice doit
se montrer aux français alors moi je
suis absolument pour qu'on montre la
justice aux français mais je pense que
les français vont être extrêmement déçu
par l'état dans lequel se trouve notre
justice aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si
c'est une bonne idée de film et surtout
de diffuser ça me pose un certain nombre
de problèmes film est pourquoi pas les
audiences mais lesquels est-ce que c'est
seulement les assises ce que on ira
aussi dans les correctionnel pourquoi
pas mais que va-t-on faire avec les
procédures civiles dans lesquelles il ya
quand même un certain nombre de secrets
des affaires par exemple qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de dévoiler ni de montrer à tout le
monde
en revanche dans le procès pénal il y a
des choses qu'il serait parfaitement
bonne de filmer par exemple on filme
bien en matière criminelle les auditions
de témoins
les auditions des accusés lorsque nous
sommes en enquête
pourquoi pas mais après pourquoi en
faire pour les diffuser les diffuser
alors sur une si j'ai bien compris sur
une chaîne qui serait dédié
ça existe peut-être dans d'autres pays
que le nôtre méfie
allemand pourquoi faire en vrai et
est-ce qu'il n'ya pas et ça je crois
quand même que la réponse est assez
positive est ce qu'il n'ya pas d'autre
idée à creuser pour d'autres réformes
qu'il serait urgentissime de mener comme
l'état désastreux dans lequel se trouve
notre justice je donne juste un exemple
un mail à personnellement j'attends une
décision depuis un an et demi qui n'est
pas encore rédigée et qu'il n'est pas
encore signé par magistrats et c'est un
tribunal correctionnel de la région
parisienne qui a vendu cette décision
donc c'est un exemple mais j'en aurais
tellement d'autre qu' on en aurait pas
assez d'une seule soirée pour raconter
tout ce qui se passe dans cette justice
qui ne fonctionnent plus alors qu'à
voilà en tout cas on va rester un
justement sur cette volonté de filmer
les audiences alors vincent berger
florence rault nous disait bien pourquoi
pas il ya il ya des choses effectivement
qu'on pourrait qu'il serait bon film et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce que
c'est une proposition populiste qui
ferait peut-être basculé la justice dans
le spectacle alors contrairement à ma
consoeur le pénaliste moi je ne suis pas
un avocat pénaliste
mais a priori je suis extrêmement
réservée des avis de cette proposition
moi je comprends parfaitement le soucier
du garde des sceaux de vouloir expliquer
aux tout grand public le fonctionnement
d'injustice le déroulement des audiences
etc
mais je crois que le moyen qui le
propose n'est pas le plus adapté et même
par et là on a un petit problème de
liaison là juste à les hisser revenus
annonce oui nous avons bien joué donc je
disais je suis très réservé concernant
cette opposition qui me paraît assez
dangereuse en quelque sorte
moi je ne suis pas un avocat pénaliste
mais je même si l'on se contentait des
procédures pénales qui sont les plus
grands publics pour hafid et on voit mal
l'intérêt que ça
apporterait au public moi je comprends
très bien soucis donc du garde des
sceaux de vouloir expliquer à la
population comment fonctionne la justice
parce que c'est un monde qui pour la
plupart de nos concitoyens est un monde
opaque un peu secret difficile à
comprendre avec ses différents acteurs
ces différentes procédures
ces différentes étapes et cetera donc
c'est quelque chose qui mérite d'être
expliquée mais je verrai ça davantage
dans le cadre scolaire ou peut-être même
universitaire que dans ce cadre là moi
je vois deux grands grande difficulté
même s'ils ont su se contenter de la
matière pénale pour le respect de la vie
privée des personnes notamment le droit
à l'image
mais pas seulement le droit à l'image je
m'inquiéterais aussi beaucoup pour la
sécurité dans certaines procédures pour
les témoins pour là je m'inquiéterais
énormément aussi pour les victimes
n'oubliez pas seulement les victimes
d'agressions sexuelles ou de viols mais
pour beaucoup d'autres questions
extrêmement grave et jeté en pâture
toutes ces personnes avec leurs vies
leurs inquiétudes leurs souffrances nos
appareils a porté atteinte à la dignité
des personnes
ça peut être effectivement dangereux de
vouloir filmer ses audiences aujourd'hui
oui ça peut être dangereux puis surtout
je ne vois pas l'utilité de montrer tout
ça genre ça les concerne pas c'est pas
parce que ce que les gens veulent savoir
c'est comment fonctionne la justice
or la justice elle s'est complètement
refermée sur elle même
on n'a plus accès aux magistrats ont
inclus accès au greffe on n'a plus accès
à rien on nous fait des palais de
justice qui sont de véritables bunkers
où vous avez
si vous avez un badge est autorisé et
ils sont rares et chères enfin en argent
bien sûr mais si vous n'êtes pas
autorisé vous ne rentrez nulle part ça
n'a plus aucun sens donc d'une certaine
manière on veut vulgariser la justice on
veut la montrer aux français
ça c'est très louable on veut leur
expliquer comment ça marche
moi je suis toujours partante pour ça
pour expliquer les procédures et pour
dire aux gens ce qu'ils peuvent attendre
pas attendre mais maintenant à les
montrer un procès sur une chaîne de télé
n'importe laquelle
à tout le monde et à n'importe qui je
crois que mon confrère a raison même si
l'epa pénaliste il touche effectivement
des points essentiels
pourquoi les dévoiler un certain nombre
de choses qui ne doit pas sûr montrer à
tout le monde qui n'a pas forcément les
outils pour comprendre tout ça alors je
vais tempéré mon propos quand même parce
que faisant exerçant en droit pénal
c'est vrai que parfois j'aurais
tellement vu qu'un procès d'assises
soient filmés alors qu'on n'a pas le
droit de le faire j'aurais tellement
envie de filmer certains échanges
certain regard certaines attitudes de
certains acteurs des procès et pas
forcément les victimes ou les fins les
gens qui participent mais mais mais
parfois certains magistrats certains
parquetier voir comment les choses se
dérouler pouvoir l'utiliser ensuite dans
un procès en appel
ça ça me paraît très très intéressant
jeudi en circonstance il me semble que
filmer les débats pourraient être finie
excellente chose mais pas forcément pour
ce que l'on veut en faire et elle que
cette annonce vincent berger
effectivement est ce que ça pourrait
faire finalement évoluer aussi le lin
l'institution le fait de rendre publics
tous ces débats peut-être mais le coût à
payer je viens de dire me paraîtrait
exorbitants bien sûr et parce que films
mais seulement les juges quel serait
l'intérêt film est simplement l'accusé
quel serait l'intérêt là un procès c'est
tout un ensemble c'est une sorte de
pièce de théâtre avec de très nombreux
les acteurs
qui s'influencent mutuellement et donc
isolé une seul à seul acteur ou une
seule catégorie d'acteurs serait à mon
avis aussi
mais le inacceptable donc moi ce qui me
frappe beaucoup c'est que c'est une des
exigences de la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme c'est qu'il faut
que le procès soit public et
naturellement les audiences plupart des
audiences civiles mais aussi de toutes
les affaires le en principe pénales sont
accessibles au public
ça permet aux citoyens qui veulent se
déplacer de contrôle est en quelque
sorte bon fonctionnement d'un juge
alors on a évidemment d'importance mais
à mon avis jusqu'à exiger que les procès
soit filmé et diffusé sur le net
florence euros le mot de la fin
comment est ce que vous comprenez
qu'aujourd'hui finalement eric dupond
moretti ont fait cette proposition alors
je ne sais pas c'est peut-être son
ancienne l'expérience professionnelle
qu'il amène à considérer comme moi que
parfois on aurait bien envie quand même
d'avoir des traces de ce qui se dit à
une audience de ce qui s'y déroule
maintenant je comprends qu'il a aussi
envie de faire bouger les lignes mais
est ce que ce sont ces lignes à qu'il
faut faire bouger si on doit dépenser de
l'argent dans une réforme de la justice
il y as peut-être une façon de rendre
cette justice accessibles d'autres
manières que celle de films et de
diffuser comme ça à un public non averti
pour en plus pour informer les gens pour
les rendre averti précisément je pense
qu'il ya d'autres moyens en tout cas
nous dans la justice nous avocats au
quotidien il ya des choses dont on
aurait cruellement besoin les magistrats
auraient aussi cruellement besoin de
moyens et nous sommes tous démunis alors
avec cette justice moribonde en valais
la montre et devant des caméras de
télévision
je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire pour
moi ça n'a pas grand sens en revanche à
d'autres choses que j'aimerais voir
proposer comme par exemple à
était de faire des facs pour accéder à
des greffes les facs existe bientôt plus
et on est obligé de faire des vagues
dans certaines circonstances il ya des
réseaux virtuels qui devrait exister
mais qui marchent pas enfin vous voyez
on marche un peu sur la tête
donc moi je veux bien qu'on a démontré
tout ça à la télévision pourquoi pas
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation florence rouge
rappelle que vous êtes avocate pénaliste
merci à vous également vincent berger
avocat spécialiste du droit
international et dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la reprise des
négociations post ben brik site avec un
neuvième round de pourparlers entre
bruxelles et londres est toujours la
perspective d'un audit qui pelade puis
direction les états unis j - avant le
débat entre donald trump et joe biden à
près d'un mois du scrutin présidentiel
restez avec nous sur rt france
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dans des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement
oui j'ai un wagon pour le valais est
décédé pourquoi aujourd'hui le président
et candidat à sa propre succession
estimant que les plus en retard à est
celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face au public se pose à nous
tant au niveau interne ou externe un
climat particulier en ce moment en côte
d'ivoire était violence sous prétexte
dont une manifestation et d'expression
de droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on estime m est-ce
que sincèrement vous êtes certains que
le scrutin du 31 octobre sera maintenu à
la date prévue
il n'y a pas de raison que ce scrutin ne
soit pas maintenu
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme s'est pas toute
fiabilité du projet nice comme ils
disent là si on oscille entre 92 et 98
points 5 % ça fonctionne bien ça permet
un d'être rapide d'être non invasif et
puis d'avoir le résultat de façon
instantanée avec un coût qui est quand
même bien moindre plus que sont les
coûts actuels du pcr on va pas sauver
l'humanité souffrent pour révolutionner
les choses avec le travail qu'on fait
aux peut-être faire en sorte qu'on fasse
appel à un savoir faire et savoir faire
médical aussi dans un domaine un peu
différente et celui de l'animal mais
après tout l'homme c'est un animal
complot
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française l'élection présidentielle aux
états unis à présent dans 36 jours
exactement
en attendant la campagne fait rage
nouvel angle d'attaqué des démocrates
contre donald trump la fiche
d'imposition du président américain
selon le new york times
le candidat républicain aurait versé
aucun centime au fisc au cours des 10 de
10 des 15 dernières années
florian lambert donald trump de nouveau
au coeur d'une polémique
le new york times révèle que le
président des états unis n'aurait payé
que 750 dollars d'impôts fédéraux en
2016 l'année de son élection
ainsi qu'en 2017 le quotidien new
yorkais va plus loin et affirme que
donald trump n'aurait versé aucun
centime aux impôts au cours des dix des
quinze dernières années et que le
candidat républicain a déclaré près d'un
milliard de dollars de pertes
en 1995 ce qui lui aurait permis
légalement d'échapper à l'impôt sur le
revenu pendant près de 20 ans des
révélations qui tombent au mauvais
moment pour le président américain
quelques semaines avant l'élection
présidentielle des accusations
auxquelles donald trump a aussitôt
répondu lors d'une conférence de presse
ce sont des informations bidon
totalement inventé des faits que news
c'est la même histoire qu'avant vous
auriez pu me poser la même question il y
a quatre ans j'ai dû régler ça et je me
suis exprimé à ce propos en réalité je
paye des impôts et vous verrez ça dès
que ma déclaration qui est sous contrôle
mes déclarations sont sous contrôle
depuis longtemps le fisc américain ne me
traite pas bien il me traite comme si
j'étais le tea party comme il traitait
le tea party
donald trump a déjà refusé à plusieurs
reprises de publier ses déclarations de
revenus en affirmant que celle ci
faisait l'objet d'un audit une rupture
avec la tradition des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle américaine et
un manque de transparence qui alimente
les spéculations sur le président des
états unis
candidat à sa propre succession et pour
en parler nous sommes avec antoinette
laurin vice présidente de république et
d' in france antoinette lors un merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
comme on peut le voir sur votre pull
vous soutenez le candidat trump un
candidat qui l'assurent les informations
concernant sa situation fiscale sont
fausses
il a toujours refusé de dévoiler ses
déclarations fiscales
est ce que finalement c'est quand même
pas une épine dans le pied du président
américain en pleine campagne électorale
non c'est pas dit qu'il dakar on fait le
biais de départ qui aura lieu demain
soir ils ont sorti cette information qui
est complètement lié par son avis crack
qui s'appelle alencar qui est quand même
que président entrant par payer des
millions des dizaines de millions d
euros de dollars aux impôts américains
et ce qui est normal c'est que président
en tant qu ils ne gagnaient pas de
saveur effarant président des états unis
en fait c'est qu'ils ont oublié c'est
que la vapeur qui donne on s'irrite et
son salaire qui est nos moments à peu
près 400 mille dollars par an aux
autorités américains alors je pense que
c'est une campagne de diffamation de new
york times et la campagne et des trompes
a demandé de démontrer ses documents et
le new york a gagné a refusé de donner
ses documents et c'est vrai que ce n'est
plus une campagne de diffamation
mais je suis convaincu que ses
supporteurs ne vont pas changer leur
avis par rapport à l'or le président
donald trump on l'a entendu lui parle de
le feq news
que c'est alors comment peut-il le
prouver aujourd'hui très concrètement
même pourquoi ne le fait-il pas à la
veille de ce débat décision parce
qu'abidal ils ont imprimé des t-shirts
en disant que moi je paye puisque trouve
c'était une manouvre des campagnes de la
côte est de 2 byden pour pour des
crudités et présidente en mai ce qui est
drôle c'est que si c'est le meilleur
démarrage que les compagnes des débats
d'une maison c'est c'est pas grand chose
les supporteurs des trompes je vous
assure ne vont pas changer du ravi par
un port de sète rapport de new york à
qui ils ont perdu totalement ma priorité
par rapport de 12 pages rythme au
terrorisme ils ont perdu doit
crédibilité par aborder pas à donner les
sources du 12 12 histoire en fait le
numéro 30
autrefois c'était une bonne piste de
milliards qui étaient bien réputé mais
depuis trois quatre cinq ans ils ont une
balance quand tu vas présidente - parce
que lui il ne tombe pas dans noir du
système de des gauchistes ça ça vient
d'où alors finalement ce montant c'est
vrai qu'ils interpellent ce montant de
750 euros d'impôts fédéraux en 2016 qui
auraient été payées par le président
c'est 750 euros d'impôts effectivement
c'est un terme elle sait assez peu pour
un président américain pour de nos repas
lors il sort d'où ce chiffre mais
complètement en fait il a renouvelé la
poste en washington dc idées à des
crédits d'impôt d'hommes ce genre des
projets qui sont tout à fait légaux
légaux et le
notre camp mais en fait il perd beaucoup
de crédibilité dans cette histoire parce
que on sait bien que président trompent
ils travaillent gratuitement depuis
trois ans et il ne faut aucune salaire
même si ça vaut 400 mille dollars par an
et donne entièrement son salaire au
mérite et américains alors c'est normal
qu'il ne paie pas d impôt idiot leurs
parents symboliquement et cela doit
pouvoir le prouver
assez rapidement selon vous où il faut
qu'il le fasse pour les devants les
américains selon m en fait en fait
l'équipe légale des présidents ils ont
demandé quelles sont vos sources new
york times
et est-ce que vous pouvez nous
fournissez d'arguments et de ne pas
fournir ces documents
alors ce n'est pas possible de combattre
à une accusation comme ça si il donne
pas les sources
en plus si elle un peu l'habitude des
côtés des démocrates harry reid il a
fait la même chose en 2012 contre mitt
romney
il a dit que vous n'avez pas payé des
impôts
il a mis sa seule d'un mécénat et
finalement il avait trompé ça c'est
dommage parce que c'est vrai que ça
c'est la seule accusation que les
québécois ils ont contraire président 30
qui a vraiment en vraies cordes très
propre alors en tout cas c'est dans ce
contexte demain qui aura lieu le premier
débat entre donald trump et joe biden à
quoi est-ce que l'on peut s'attendre
selon vous évader tribales sans doute
vous voulez dire qu'est ce que vous le
supportez vous êtes une militante on le
rappelle médiatique mais en fait by dell
et peut pas répondre en casque euros il
est vraiment une pétition depuis 47 ans
il a vécu sur le dos des des impôts
sable
car depuis 47 ans et n'a rien changé
depuis 47 ans et pourquoi les électeurs
électorale américaine vont porter que ça
va changer avec by dell s'est totalement
n'importe quoi
by de l île est sénile et les vraiment
pas en santé pour devenir président en
est vraiment on va voir ça demain soir
ça fait effectivement c'est votre avis
est ce que dit aussi régulièrement de
l'iphone en tout cas au niveau des
sondages au 28 septembre 2020 49 8% pour
joe biden 42 9%
pour donald trump donc soit près de 7
points de plus pour john hayden est ce
que le demande
alors je vous donne la source dans un
instant que je n'ai pas sur moi et en
tout cas est ce que le sondage pourrait
donner la donne et comment les sondages
ne compte pour pas grand chose
élan si on peut faire un petit rappel en
1984 c'était la même situation entre
présidents brienne et monde elle est
freinée
il a tourné tout les pays en républicain
et je soupçonne que ça va être d'accord
malgré les sondages malgré les les
les accusations de totalement fausses
contrat dupont
on va voir que la plupart des américains
on peut dire les majorités silencieuses
on n'est pas pour casser une autre
histoire on n'est pas pour faire les
foules boulet nos villes et nos bonnes
je n'ai pas peur
en fait font voir ce qui se passe avec
la gauche soutenue par peut-être obama
part peut-être par george soros et nous
on ne voit pas si ces genres de
comportements comme une solution pour
améliorer la mairie
oui notre pays alors comment vous pouvez
aider fortement possible que nous allons
gagner et le sénat et les prési
dentielle et moi je crois à 100% que la
plupart des américains vont voter contre
ce genre de comportement violent non
acquises actions en bourse alors et j'y
suis je reviens effectivement sur le
sondage a lancé un sondage réussir
politique et puis un autre sondage du
centre d'écouté tea dance à l'université
de caen 538 et d havas baisse dans les
sondages et peut il prendre un petit
parti dévot des électorats et il entend
effectivement ça ça donne un cap ça n'a
jamais effectivement donné les résultats
dans beaucoup d'excès de l'ex y ont
d'ailleurs peut-être pour conclure il ya
eu des manifestations violentes qui se
sont multipliées ces derniers mois aux
etats-unis alors à qui profites t'elle
selon vous en vue des élections
bien sûr ça c'est la stratégie de la
gauche mais je pense que ça va ça va
backfire ça va en fait les devenir le
détruit mon allure partie parce que de
toute part des américains qui croient
dans les manifestations de paix on a là
doit tout à fait de manifester contre
notre gouvernement
mais dans notre façon de paix pour une
façon formuler les villes sans brûler
les versements sont volés les les
entreprises des autres américains et
ceux qui disent que blake lively ce
batteur en fait et boules les
entreprises à répondre décoiffe les deux
resteront
et son entrée elle dû détruire nos
propres supporteurs et ça va vraiment
merci en tout cas on doit être heureux
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes vice présidente
de république and in france
reprise ce mardi des négociations post
break site
un neuvième et normalement dernier round
de pourparlers entre bruxelles et
londres
un point de désaccord persistent la
frontière avec l'irlande du nord le
texte en cours d'examen au parlement
britannique revient sur certaines
dispositions qui avaient été prises afin
d'éviter le retour d'une frontière avec
le pays voisin
une mesure jugée essentielle au maintien
de la paix sur l'île selon l'union
européenne a les européens furieux de ce
revirement de la part de londres avait
donné au royaume uni jusqu'à ce mercredi
pour retirer leurs projets sous peine
d'un recours en justice
ce que le vice président de la
commission européenne maros sefcovic n'a
pas hésité à rappeler aujourd'hui
important de dire selon une enquête de
la confédération de l'industrie
britannique la cbi 77 % des entreprises
souhaitent qu'un accord soit trouvé
un pourcentage qui dépasse 80% parmi les
fabricants et les distributeurs
seuls 4% des sociétés préférées breakes
site sans accord l'activité du secteur
privé continue de reculer elle a connu
une baisse de 23% sur les trois derniers
mois c'est moins que le trimestre
précédent qui enregistrait -39%
mais ce recul reste considérable les
entreprises britanniques font
actuellement face à un triple enjeu
relancer l'activité après la crise du
covin 19 faire face à une nouvelle vague
du virus et se préparer au changement
dans les relations commerciales avec
l'union européenne
sand hill 50 à 70% des grandes
entreprises 20 à 40% des petites et
moyennes entreprises ne seraient pas
prêtes le 31 décembre 2020 pour
appliquer les nouvelles exigences de
européenne estime le gouvernement
britannique la cbi appelle les européens
et le gouvernement britannique à un
accord le moment est venu pour le
leadership politique et l'esprit de
compromis de transparaître des deux
côtés un accord peut et doit être conclu
et direction l'espagne à présent qui
prend des mesures restrictives plus
contraignante la communauté de madrid
étant le confinement partiel depuis ce
matin 15 % des près de 7 millions
d'habitants de la région sont concernés
par les restrictions liées à la
résurgence du coït 19 ramia berrada il
flottait comme une impression de déjà vu
dans les rues madrilènes en ce début de
semaine des parcs boucler des jardins
d'enfants déserté
cent soixante sept mille habitants
supplémentaires de la capitale espagnole
sont invités à rester chez eux à compter
de ce lundi
au total ce sont désormais 850 mille
personnes qui sont concernées par le
confinement partielle de la ville
des milliers d'habitants qui ne peuvent
sortir de leur quartier qu'en cas de
nécessité comme pour aller travailler se
rendre chez le médecin ou emmener les
enfants à l'école
de nouvelles restrictions accueillie de
façon mitigée par les riverains
cela fait plus de quarante ans que nous
vivons ici pour les personnes âgées la
situation est critique nous devons
essayer d'aller de l'avant sans
enfreindre les règles j'espère que les
gens sont conscients de l'importance de
porter un masque et de respecter ce qui
nous a été demandé de faire ce que les
politiciens devraient faire plutôt que
de se livrer une bataille c'est de
trouver rapidement un vaccin
le bras de fer auquel fait référence cet
habitant c'est celui qui oppose la
région de madrid et le gouvernement
central
ce dernier estime que les autorités
locales malgré l'élargissement du
confinement partiel à de nouvelles zones
ne vont pas assez loin et menacent
d'imposer des mesures drastiques dans
les quartiers les communes défavorisées
du sud de la capitale particulièrement
visé par les restrictions les
manifestations se multiplient avec un
mot d'ordre forcer le gouvernement à
investir davantage dans la santé
publique
ce que la région de madrid fait pour
combattre la pandémie est totalement
insuffisant
ce que nous voulons tous c'est que les
ressources et l'argent que détiennent le
gouvernement central et la région
soit investi dans la santé publique afin
de la renforcer nous sommes ici pour
faire valoir notre dignité en tant que
population
nous sommes ici parce qu'ils nous ont
abandonnés et nous avons l'impression
d'être retourné dans les années 80 quand
les habitants mourait à cause de la
drogue et maintenant ils veulent nous
voir mourir du virus depuis la
résurgence de la pandémie dans le pays
madrid est devenu l'épicentre des
contaminations à ce jour l'espagne
comptabilise plus de 700 mille cas et
plus de 31000 mort du coronavirus
confirmation par le tribunal suprême
espagnol de la condamnation à un an et
demi d'inéligibilité de klimt aura une
décision qui entraîne la destitution du
président indépendantiste régional
catalan condamné en première instance en
décembre il avait refusé de retirer une
banderole au contenu séparatistes de la
façade du siège du gouvernement régional
avant les élections législatives d'avril
2010 9 son vice président doit assurer
l'intérim
le point à barcelone avec leslie singla
kim tora le président de la région
catalane est destitué la cour de
cassation espagnole a confirmé la
sentence du tribunal
il est donc condamné à une peine
d'inégibilité de 18 mois et une amende
de 30000 euros pour délit de
désobéissance
alors c'était au printemps 2010 9 en
pleine campagne électorale pour les
élections législatives européennes et
municipales team toro avait refusé de
retirer un message politique affichée
sur la façade du siège de la catalogne
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
et ce message affiché liberté aux
prisonniers
il est politique en soutien aux hommes
politiques indépendantistes catalans
incarcéré pour tentative de sécession en
2017 alors la commission électorale
avait indiqué que ce message est donc
politique mais surtout qu'il vient le la
neutralité des bâtiments publics
institutionnels
de ce fait le tribunal suprême a estimé
que kim torah a désobéi de façon
obstinée pour les indépendantistes il
s'agit d'une nouvelle provocation de
madrid et donc pour protester contre
cette sentence
ils ont convoqué des rassemblements à
barcelone et dans toute la catalogne
et puis en afrique maintenance et la
réouverture des écoles dit inquiète le
plus grand syndicat d'enseignants du
zimbabwe est en grève pour réclamer des
augmentations de salaires et ce alors
que le gouvernement relâche ces mesures
restrictives prix pierre jan mazari avec
les mre le court
des visages démasqué dans les rues des
principales villes du pays
jusqu'à maintenant le zimbabwe et ses
quelques 14 millions d'habitants ont été
relativement épargnées par le
coronavirus une situation qui pousse le
gouvernement à assouplir les gestes
barrière à la plus grande satisfaction
des habitants comme ici à chitungwiza au
sud darar la capitale on avait
particulièrement peur pendant les trois
premières semaines du confinement mais
aujourd'hui plus du tout voilà c'est
pour cela que je ne porte plus le masque
il n'y a plus de coronavirus mais cette
baisse de vigilance inquiète les
organisations de santé
rosemary et travailleuse communautaire
et tous les jours elle fait du porte à
porte pour sensibiliser les familles
face au danger que représente le coït 19
notre travail est maintenant plus
difficile parce que les gens n'ont plus
peur
certains nous disent même qu'ils ne
craignent plus le virus parce qu'il n'a
tué personne dans leur entourage
il ajoute qu'ils ont plus peur du vih
parce qu'il a tué beaucoup de personnes
autour d'eux si le zimbabwe est aussi
peu touchés par le cos vite 19 c'est
grâce à une mise en place rapide des
mesures strictes pour endiguer sa
propagation selon les instances
sanitaires du pays
toutefois ces mêmes instances
avertissent le gouvernement n'hésitera
pas à remettre en place des mesures
restrictives en cas de résurgence de
l'épidémie et c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve dans quelques
minutes pour 1 point complet sur
l'actualité rester avec nous sur rt
france a tout de suite
m
est ce que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature du pdc y votre parti reste
crédible
à partir du moment où le plaisir et
colombier revient dans la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on peut
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
librement d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de correction nous
allons retrouver le pouvoir planier
cette élection et il n'y aura pas de
chasse aux sorcières que les partisans
du rhdp se rassurent nous n'avons pas
les poursuivre pour des fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près des warnings
[Musique]
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et l'info karl de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant mais
on se remet à vivre mais dans une autre
direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait ça jamais plaint d'une
décision invraisemblable pour vos ça
dépend telles valeurs on attribuait la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes même
individuel avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral des baltique
[Musique]